[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: So you
recently published
a book titled "Trust."
Usually-- oh, there, at this
point, you hold it up, and--
available on Amazon, I'm sure.
"Twenty Ways to Build
a Better Country."
Of all the things you could
pick to focus on, why trust?
DAVID JOHNSTON:
Well, the book is
dedicated to children who
offer their trust instinctively
and with full
expectation of fairness.
It's interesting, the children.
We have five daughters
and 14 grandchildren.
And I say, all the
important things in life,
I've learned from my children
and I'm now re-learning
from my grandchildren.
And it sounds like it's jest.
It really isn't jest.
When you see the world through
the lens of your children
and grandchildren, it gives
you a different perspective,
including a long-term
perspective.
The reason we wrote the
"Trust" book, Steve,
is a bit of a history.
When I was installed as governor
general in October 2010,
the title of my
installation address
was, "A smart and
caring nation, a call
to service" with three pillars.
Family and Children.
Learning and Innovation.
Philanthropy and Volunteerism.
And we began to pursue
projects, outreach activities
using the office of the governor
general for that purpose
and established the Rideau
Hall Foundation in 2012
to be the institutional
focus of those activities.
And I then concluded that
there is no power in the job,
but you do have a platform.
And you're trying to
reinforce fundamental values
of Canadians.
And so we tried to
use the office, then,
as a bit of a bully pulpit.
And I began writing
a little differently.
I'm a law professor,
so I've written
a whole lot of law books that
are very dull and boring,
and a page of them will put
you to sleep at night if you
have difficulty sleeping.
But I began to write books.
And the first one was called,
"The Idea of Canada, Letters
to a Nation."
I'm a morning letter writer.
I'll tell you more about
that if we have time.
But it was people alive--
and some who were deceased--
that I would be
having conversations
with about the fundamental
values of the country.
And then Tom Jenkins
and I decided
that we wanted to put a
spotlight in innovation.
So we had created the governor
general's Innovation Awards
to celebrate
innovators in Canada.
But we began collecting
stories for a book,
and we thought 50 would be fine.
And we quickly got to 50.
We said 150 for our 150th year.
We got to 297.
The publisher
says, that's as far
as you go in that
size of a book.
So we stopped there.
But we created a website
to post those stories
and others of innovation,
including social innovation.
And then we did a
children's edition
of that book, which
we're trying to place
in every school in the country.
And Amy, who is here with
me, and one of her colleagues
have been seconded from
the government of Canada
running the Innovation Program.
In fact, one of the
highlights of that
is Canada Innovation Week, which
is the last 10 days in May.
It'll be the third
one this year.
And with those books, then--
and I come now to
your question--
I became increasingly concerned
about the erosion of trust,
particularly in our public
institutions, but beyond that,
and decided that I would write
a book, which initially began
as looking at trust as a social
characteristic of countries,
the rule of law, the
institutions of government,
and so on.
And then I realized
that that really
sprang from how organizations,
and communities,
and neighborhoods
worked in a country.
And then I realized
that that sprang
from how each of
us as individuals
become trustworthy people.
And so out of it has
come 20 characteristics
that follow that narrative,
beginning with, make
herself a trustworthy person.
Then the next part of
the narrative of the arc
is, how you build trustworthy
organizations like the ones you
serve here at Google,
or your neighborhood,
or your community, or
your church, et cetera,
and then how you build
a trustworthy country.
SPEAKER: That's
certainly going to be
a topic for the next time,
it seems, in our country.
So in your opinion,
how bad is it?
DAVID JOHNSTON:
Well, I think trust
as we've known it classically
certainly has seen an erosion.
Trust is kind of a funny word.
It's a very simple concept.
It is reliability.
It's fairness.
It's honesty.
And that's the noun.
And the verb is the willingness
to put your trust in something.
And that's why we began
with that statement
about children who
instinctively place their trust
and have an expectation
of fairness.
And I guess, as I
watch the world,
particularly in the
last seven years as GG,
I saw a continual
erosion of that.
Edelman does a survey
worldwide, done for about 10,
20 years now.
And they've marked a steady
deterioration in trust.
And Canada, two years
ago, for the first time
became a distruster nation.
That is, less than
50% of our population
trusted their governments, their
nongovernmental organizations,
the media, and,
in fact, business
to act in trustworthy ways.
The good news for you in this
audience from the Edelman
survey is that of
those four sectors--
government, that is,
public institutions,
nongovernmental organizations,
media, and business--
it's business leaders
who have the highest
degree of trust of those four.
Used to be the lowest,
it's now the highest.
And I think there's an
expectation in that somewhat
distrusting populace that
business leaders will
lead the effort to rebuild
trust in our institutions.
SPEAKER: That's
very interesting.
We obviously talk
about these kind
of issues and our
relationships all of the time,
both as a company
and as Canadians,
largely operating here.
So how do we stabilize this?
How do we revive trust?
And how do we get
going as Canadians?
DAVID JOHNSTON:
Well, I think we try
to understand why it is eroding
if you accept that it is.
And then very fundamentally, we
live in an age of disruption.
And when you have high
degrees of disruption,
as you read history,
the moorings
of traditional practices
tend to come loose.
And there's a degree of
uncertainty and uneasiness.
And I think that
three big factors that
have been so dramatically
changing for us
would be the technological
disruption that we've seen,
where, in fact,
the pace of changes
is a trajectory like that.
It's increasing in
acceleration, and our ability
to adjust to it-- the
human capacity to adjust--
is operating like that.
So we have that gap
of change coming
faster than we seem to be able
to manage in traditional ways.
That creates uneasiness.
The second thing, I would say,
is the rising inequalities
of wealth around the
world, but particularly
in the developed
societies, where
you have expectation levels
that are very, very different
and a sense of despair,
a sense of grievance,
in those populations that
feel left out in that process.
Then a third thing that I
think has been very disruptive
for us is, perhaps,
that coming to the end
of the Western consensus in
international matters that
prevailed from World War II
on, be it international trade,
be it peace and
security matters,
be it dealing with conflict--
we have more displaced
persons in the world
today than we've ever had
with the conflicts, et cetera.
And if you think of
right after World War II,
the Marshall Plan was
the US-led initiative
to put Germany and Japan
back on their feet.
Rarely in history have
you seen a situation
where the conqueror would
say, having conquered,
we now will do everything
within our power
to help you rebuild
a civil society.
World War I ended in
just the opposite way
and it led to World War II.
Maybe we learned from that.
But out of that became the
International Monetary Fund,
the Bretton Woods Agreement,
a revived United Nations.
And a consensus on international
trade is a good thing.
Globalization will
be a good thing.
That has been a
factor that's eroded.
So we face that, and
I use the expression--
it's an 18th
century expression--
that "trust comes in on foot
and goes out on horseback."
And Mark Carney
has rephrased it.
"Trust comes in on foot
and goes out in a Ferrari."
Just think of those metaphors.
It is quick to destroy, and
it's slow to build step by step.
But I guess through
the book, Steve,
we tried to write some of
the prescriptions of how you
rebuild trust step by step,
be it in your own life,
in your organizations that
you lead, or in a country.
And we can go into those in
some more detail as you want.
SPEAKER: Well, I'm afraid
there's a lot of analogs there
that apply to
large corporations.
I was once told when
I came to this company
it wasn't a large corporation.
And I think that's
true to some extent,
although I think we're
perceived very much as a very
large organization.
And I think that's fair.
If you had to put yourself in
the seat of an organization
such as ours, or another,
how do you re-earn--
earn trust again--
or re-earn trust?
How would you advise the
CEO to form the organization
and move forward?
DAVID JOHNSTON:
Well, first of all,
I guess, you have to know who
you are and where you're at.
I was just telling a story
over lunch with your colleagues
that I'll tell
tonight, because I'm
speaking at a gathering
at the York Club.
And Mike Wilson,
some of you remember,
is a minister of finance, a
guy I admire an awful lot,
is hosting, and
it'll be on trust.
And Mike was Canada's
ambassador to the United States.
And I said, Mike, we needed
you there in Washington
in the last year and
renegotiating the Canada/US
Free Trade Agreement.
And this story is applicable.
Allegedly, it's the transcript
of recorded messages
that took place off the coast
of Newfoundland several decades
ago.
And it begins with Voice 1.
Attention, you are heading
towards a collision.
Recommend you alter
course 45 degrees East.
Voice 2.
You are heading
towards a collision.
Recommend you alter
course 45 degrees West.
Voice 1.
In a half a mile at
your current speed,
you will be in a
serious collision.
Change course now.
Voice 2.
I am the USS Eisenhower
aircraft carrier of the US Navy
with 100 planes aboard, with
three destroyers, and four
cruisers, and about
2,500 military personnel.
You change course now.
Voice 1.
I'm a lighthouse.
Your move.
[LAUGHTER]
Who you are and where you're at.
I think if you lead
an organization,
I think you act out
some of these things
that I've spoken about.
Listen first.
Draw from all of
the organization.
Two, share the plan
as widely as possible.
Give people ownership of it.
Ensure that you are an inclusive
organization, not simply
a diverse organization, but
an inclusive organization.
Diversity is just a
statement of fact.
You can check the boxes
of what number of females,
what number of males you
have, what visible minorities
you have, what cultural
groups you have.
That's just a statistic.
Inclusivity, of
course, is an action.
And in the Deloitte study
on diversity inclusion,
they call a paper "From
Optics to Outcomes."
How do you move from optics--
checking the boxes-- to
outcomes inclusivity,
where people actually are
engaged with one another?
And they use the
metaphor of a dance.
It's one thing to be
invited to the dance.
It's another thing to
be invited to dance.
Coming to the dance and
sitting on the sidelines,
I guess you're there.
But so what?
But getting on the dance
floor, you become inclusive.
And I like to take that
metaphor even further.
From optics, to
outcomes, to ownership--
and this is the message for
the leader of the organization.
And the time I was
at Rideau Hall,
one of the functions
of the governor general
is to receive the
letters of credential,
letters of credence, of
incoming ambassadors.
And they're not
allowed to function
until they've presented
those letters and accepted.
And we have about
200 ambassadors.
So we would-- and they served
three or four years-- so we'd
have probably 60 or 70 a year.
We'd always have at least
one ceremony once a month
to receive them early.
And then I'd spend a
little one-on-one time
with each of them.
And I'd say to each of them,
come to our winter diplomat
party.
It's really Canadian.
So in February, we would have
all the diplomats in the city
come to Rideau Hall.
And we have an
outdoor skating rink.
We believe it's the oldest
one in North America.
And I want to tell you,
thanks to our $300,000 grant
that the Foundation managed to
get that we don't have skating
4 and 1/2 months a year.
We've got a refrigeration
plant that really works.
You can make ice at
10 degrees below zero.
So we get these people
on the skating rink,
and we get them on
sleigh rides if there's
enough snow, et cetera.
And then they come in.
And there's a buffet dinner.
It's [INAUDIBLE],, the
French Quebecois cuisine,
and there's a square dance
fiddling group from Maniwaki.
And they teach these
people how to square dance
in French and in English, and
play the spoons, and so on.
And so you'll get these
people out on the dance floor.
And square dance is not
kind of a nice, soft waltz.
It's everybody in
action, and you're
bumping into one another.
And I'll tell you, do
they ever feel inclusive.
And I cannot tell you what a joy
I would get about seeing some
of the dispatches that would
go home from those diplomats
of a winter evening in Canada.
And boy, did I ever
feel inclusive.
So that's a long
story, but but that's,
I think, how you go about it.
I'll just tell one
more story, though,
because it illustrates
so much about leadership.
It's the story of Vimi Ridge.
How many of you know about
the Battle of Vimi Ridge here?
It was World War I. It was
Easter weekend in April,
and the Canadians
took Vimi Ridge,
an area of the plains
of northern France
that had been battled over
for about a year and a half
with over 100,000
French, 300,000 English,
and an equivalent
number of Germans
killed in a matter of
a few square miles.
And the Canadian group
was then commanded
by Lord Bing, who became
governor general of Canada
from 1925 to 1930, I think.
And the commander of
the first Canadian Corps
was Sir Arthur Currie, a
Canadian who later became
principal of McGill University.
And so Haig and
[INAUDIBLE],, the generals
from the French and
the English allies,
ordered Byng to try
to take Vimi Ridge.
He said, I will, but not now.
He said, we must
delay it for a month,
because Currie and I
have spoken about this,
and we need a month to prepare.
Point one.
Point two, they gave the
battle plan for this battle
to every member of the
Canadian Corps army,
including the privates.
Of course, at Headquarters,
they were appalled.
You're giving privates
the battle plan?
They'll probably lose
it in the local tavern
and the Germans will have it,
et cetera, et cetera, everyone.
And then the Canadians, of
course, were non-transcripts.
They were all volunteers.
And many were farm
boys from Saskatchewan
or places like that.
And you know a thing or
two about life there.
And they were an
irreverent sort.
They had to work pretty hard
at learning how to salute
and using titles, et cetera.
But they were
independent thinkers.
And the reason they
had the battle plan
was when the sergeant in the
platoon was injured or killed,
the corporal had to take over.
And if the corporal
were injured or killed,
a private had to take over.
They had to be able to
take responsibility.
They had to own the plan.
The next thing they did
is Andrew McNaughton
was a young professor
from McGill,
who was a scientist, who was
assigned to Arthur Currie's
headquarters.
And they were three
really bright scientists
from Cambridge University
assigned to Douglas Higgs,
the English headquarters.
They weren't being used, because
the English and French were
fighting 19th-century warfare,
cavalry and infantry men.
Tanks were not much used,
and airplanes, not at all.
But these Cambridge
guys with McNaughton
said, we're going
to use airplanes
for surveillance, point one.
Point two is, we're going to
use two principles of physics
and mathematics to have a
pinpoint sighting of where
the German guns are placed.
So they used the fact that
sound travels slower than light.
And so they would measure
the light from a flashing gun
to when the shell
landed, and they'd
measure the sound from that
gun to when it occurred
and triangulate to get the
precise location of the guns.
And then they developed, through
very precise mathematics,
what we call a creeping
barrage, creeping barrage.
The custom from the
19th-century warfare
is the guns blast the devil
out of the enemy trenches
all through the night and then
just before dawn, they stop.
And then the infantry rushes in.
Well, by the time the infantry
gets to the enemy trenches,
they're back in their trenches,
and they're waiting for them.
So what McNaughton and
Currie and Byng did
is the guns would fire
right into the morning
for a five-minute period.
Then they would stop, and
immediately, the infantry
would follow right on for
a half a kilometer or so.
And then they would
stop, and the guns
would fire again for
another, say, two minutes.
And then the infantry
would go forward
for another half kilometer.
On and on, the creeping
barrage, and it only
worked because good sighting
of the guns, but very precise
mathematics of timing
when the guns were firing,
and when they stopped, and
when the men were charging.
And that, actually,
won Vimi Ridge
in three days of
very bitter fighting
which had not been won before.
There were four or five
different lessons there,
all of which have to do with
how you lead an organization.
And what happened shortly
after that is Byng
stepped aside and
persuaded the allies
that Currie should be in command
of all of the Canadian troops.
And that was the first
time the Canadians marched
under their own leadership.
And that was the
really beginning
of the Canadian military.
Long story, but if
you want to figure out
how you lead an
organization, you
could do worse than sitting down
and reading about Vimi Ridge
and some of these lessons.
SPEAKER: Very interesting.
So as we look at some of these
20 ways of addressing trust,
we've talked, I think, just
now about sharing the plan,
which I very much like.
I think share some
real cultural elements
to how we try to do things--
maybe not quite a
dramatic fashion.
Can you talk a bit
about something
that's really meaningful task
to us right now, which is--
and you mention
it in your book--
which is about listening.
DAVID JOHNSTON: Yeah.
SPEAKER: We've been trying to
do a bit of listening ourselves
lately, and internally
and externally as well,
and do you think that
as a society, perhaps,
we've stopped listening?
And how does that affect?
DAVID JOHNSTON: Yes.
I think that's one of
those disruptive changes.
We have become less listeners
and more data gatherers.
And we have been much more
instantaneous, I think,
in our reactions.
We're a more instantaneous
society, aren't we?
It just takes longer in the old
days for things to get there.
And I think we have
to re-cultivate
the act of listening.
My grandmother used
to say, god gave you
two eyes, and two ears,
and one mouth for a reason.
Use them proportionately.
But the beauty of
listening first
is you are showing respect to
the other person or persons
in the group.
You are establishing
a bond of trust.
And bear in mind, there's
a Stephen Covey book
called "The Speed of Trust."
And his equation is, trust
equals speed plus cost.
The more trust you have built
up within an organization,
or between your organization
and another, the less costly
it is to do transactions
and the faster they occur.
You and I shake hands.
That's a handshake.
And we know that
that was pretty fast
and didn't cost us very much.
And we've got a
deal, and on we get.
So you build that trust.
By listening, what
you're also doing is
you're encouraging
everybody in the group
to own the issue, not
just your instructions.
And you follow them
out, but you own it.
The story I tell about that
is when I assumed the office
at Rideau Hall,
the person who runs
it is called the secretary
to the office of the governor
general.
We Canadians are
great for titles.
The leading public servant is
called the clerk of the Privy
Council, and the person that
ran the office of the governor
general is the
secretary of the office.
Any event, the person who
held that office retired.
And we had a competition.
And the guy we chose
was Stephen Wallace,
who is a consummately
marvelous public servant.
And when I came
into the office, I
said, where's the
strategic plan?
Where's the plan of operations
for the next five years?
There wasn't one.
I said, sure there's one.
No, there wasn't one.
Look in the archives.
Because I'm not the first
new sheriff in town.
There isn't.
We couldn't find
something that was
called like a strategic plan.
I said, well, we'll do one.
So the assignment I
gave to the four or five
shortlist candidates
for the job is just
give me the outlines
of a strategic plan.
And Stephen did something that
was beautiful, just marvelous.
So I said, OK.
Great.
How long will it take you
to craft and implement
this strategic plan?
He says, well, I can
do it over the weekend,
as a matter of fact.
But he said, I wouldn't
do that if I were you.
And I said, why not?
He said, you want to engage
every one of the 150 people
in the organization.
So we took three months.
And that's what we did.
And it was marvelous.
Because everyone in
that organization
owned the direction of the
operation for the next five
years and lived that.
And so that's a
part of listening.
And it's, again, like
optics to outcomes.
It's not just producing
a strategic plan.
It's a strategic plan
that must demonstrate
that you've actually listened.
And if you want those
150 people to own it,
they have to find their
voice in it somewhere.
And so some of the things
in the strategic plan
I wouldn't have thought
of and were good.
Some of the things I
didn't think were good,
but we tried them, and by and
large they worked out well.
But you get a sense of
ownership that is so incredible.
And I-- see, leadership
is recognizing
your total dependence on
the people around you.
That was Byng and Currie in Vimi
Ridge, the people around them.
But the job of a
leader is not just
to jump in front of
the parade and lead it,
and say, look at me, I've
got a great team, away we go.
The job of a leader is
to create an environment
where each person has
a sense of ownership
of the mission,
the vision, and is
operating at the very
maximum of their talents.
And guess what happens?
When you operate at the
maximum of your talents,
your bandwidth expands.
You become more
talented and learn
how to become more talented.
And it all begins
with listening first.
I could quote another book
about Sir William Osler,
and I won't at this moment.
But if I have another
time, I would.
Osler's book, "Principles and
of 'Medicine--
[LAUGHTER]
I love books.
My grandchildren
call me Grandpa Book.
He started his career at
McGill and then in the US.
And then he held the
Regents Chair of Medicine
at Oxford, died in 1919.
And his "Principles and
Practices of Medicine,"
his text, went through about
42 editions over 100 years--
Canada's most
influential physician.
But embedded in it was,
listen to your patient.
Don't come in and
read the charts.
Listen to your patient.
One, you're building a
trust with that patient.
Two, you're getting behind
the particular symptoms
of the illness.
And three, you're establishing
a relationship where, together,
you can provide healing.
SPEAKER: I'm going to have
to rush to get a question
or there's going to be
another story coming.
DAVID JOHNSTON: So I speak
in 55-second paragraphs.
SPEAKER: So as an organization,
as a broad organization,
we've grown a lot.
And we work hard internally
to foster and build trust.
We try to listen.
We tried to effect change.
But some of the
things in your book
really resonate with me,
particularly this concept
that you alluded to just already
about depending on one another.
And I think this is core to
our culture in many ways.
And certainly, I believe it's
fundamental to ability to lead.
Can you tell us
a little bit more
about that, about how it
affects organizational capacity?
DAVID JOHNSTON: Well, if
you depend on one another--
and you have the
suggestion box of put
in your suggestions of
how we improve things--
don't do that if you're not
really going to make it work.
If it's just window
dressing, people
get cynical about
that pretty fast
and they don't see
anything happening.
Also you want to give credit.
The leader is the last
one to take any credit.
I often say you can accomplish
anything in the world,
provided you insist on never
taking any credit for it--
but also the first one
to take responsibility.
I mean, responsibility,
that's an important feature
of depending on the
people around you,
that you share the
credit widely--
and you should.
Because if you've done
this inclusivity right,
if you shared the strategic
plan right, people own it.
It belongs to them.
And so when things go
well, they should feel
pretty good to get the credit.
On the other hand, when things
go wrong, you, as the leader,
have the responsibility.
Now, your team will
probably come along and say,
we made a big mistake.
How to repair it?
But it's two different
approaches to the same.
Again, to come back to Rideau
Hall, it's interesting.
When Stephen came and began
with his strategic plan,
we had about a 50% response
rate to the annual survey
that the government
of Canada would
do of staff in a particular
section of satisfaction,
job development, et cetera.
And by and large, the
results were sort of average.
Over the five years
of his leadership,
we had dramatic improvements
in the participation
in that survey and
dramatic improvements
in the positive and quality
responses, so much so
that in the last
year that I was there
and Stephen was there with
me, the OECD published
its annual rankings of the
performance of public servants
around the world.
There are 33 OECD countries.
Canada was number one.
And one of the surveys of
top employers just shortly
after that for the Ottawa
region showed our office
as top employer for the region.
So Stephen and I sent a note
to all of the people saying,
you probably are aware
of the OECD study.
You are part of the leading
professionals, public service
group of these 33 countries.
Pretty good.
And by the way, you've just been
named part of the top employer
in the region.
You're the créme de la créme.
And that, you know,
is in a sense sharing
credit with everyone there.
It was pretty good for the
morale in the organization.
SPEAKER: We met in the
context of community building
a while back.
And not surprisingly, you
talk about this importance
in the book.
But can you tell
us why [AUDIO OUT]
DAVID JOHNSTON: I used to
give a speech called, "What's
in the water in Waterloo?"
And it was a slide presentation.
And the first slide
showed the Grand River
flowing through the community.
Pretty nice to have
a river goes by.
And we live just
west of Heidelberg
on a farm in Mennonite country.
So our neighbors are all
horse-and-buggy people.
And they were absolutely
lovely people.
Couldn't imagine
better neighbors.
And we would be invited to
go on barn-raising exercises.
I think, a couple times
there was a barn burned down
or something burned down.
And we were so honored to
be included in the community
to go on the Saturday
to clean up the debris,
and begin to rebuild
the barn, et cetera.
And so the second
slide is actually
an overhead, aerial photo of
a barn-raising with Mennonites
rebuilding or building
a brand new barn.
And men, women, boys,
girls are all there
helping with their
contribution of time
and their contribution
of also the wood
and the different materials.
And so that's the second slide.
The third slide is
the second slide.
And the first slide is the
barn raising in the water.
It's that barn-raising concept,
that collaborative concept,
that is so much a feature
of this community.
And barn raising is a metaphor
of how we collaborate.
And why do we do that?
We do it because we're
trying to make life
not only good for ourselves and
our family, but our neighbors.
And the most
fundamental principle
of all of the ones
in the "Trust" book
is the golden rule--
treat your neighbors as you
would have yourself treated.
And I think that notion
of making life better
for everyone in your community
is a very important feature
of any healthy community.
You can almost measure the
health of the community
by the degree of
collaboration there is
and how well the golden
rule is practiced.
It's very interesting.
I was at an economics conference
about three, four years ago.
And I was speaking, I
guess, on innovation.
And Robert Shiller, the Nobel
Prize economist from Yale--
he does the Shiller Case
Housing index, for example--
was speaking.
And I stayed on beyond
my contribution.
I was supposed to be, I
guess, back in the office.
But I want to stay
on, because I wanted
to hear Robert Shiller,
the Nobel Prize
winner in behavioral
economics [INAUDIBLE]..
And to my enormous surprise,
in his half-hour address,
he didn't speak about
economics at all.
He spoke about the golden rule.
And he said that
if you look at all
of the great religions
of the world,
they all have the golden rule
at their heart, expressed
different ways,
but at their heart.
And then he said
something that I often
quote to my business friends.
He says, Adam Smith would
be considered the father
of modern capitalism.
In his book, "The Wealth
of Nations," in 1773,
is considered kind of the
Bible, or the early Bible
for the modern capitalistic
market-based society.
People forget that
Adam Smith was not
the professor of economics
at Glasgow University.
He was the professor
of moral theory.
And his even more important book
than the "Wealth of Nations"
was the "Theory of
Moral Sentiment."
And the invisible hand,
which we have interpreted
that to guide the marketplace
to produce a harmonious outcome
for everyone seeking
private profit,
was not an invisible hand
that permitted that market--
free market-- to
operate smoothly.
The invisible hand was
the moral framework
that oversaw and held
together the markets which,
from time to time,
needed regulation.
People in a free market
can move into cartels
pretty easily if you give them
a chance to conspire together,
and on and on.
That's contained in "The
Wealth of Nations" as well.
But it's the part that
people don't read very much.
But that invisible
hand, of course,
was something that was
based on the golden rule.
And so to come back to
your question, Steve,
why do you want a
community to function
in a collaborative way?
Because you want it to be
a good place to live in.
You want it to be a place
where people have a chance
to develop their
talents to the full
and where their lives are
safe and secure, et cetera.
And you want to have vigorous,
competitive enterprise that
is constantly innovating
and trying to make
not only its products
and services better,
but the whole community better.
And that got us, at
lunch, on to my tale
of why we need a tertiary
teaching hospital here
in this community.
SPEAKER: And we're
still working on it.
DAVID JOHNSTON:
And why all of you
have such a contribution to make
to the leadership of community
projects like that and
so many other things.
We have something called
the Sovereign's Medal
in Volunteerism--
another story.
I'm going on too much.
But it was the
Caring Canadian Award
that was offered by
the governor general.
And it was started
by Roméo LeBlanc.
Roméo was an Acadian from Nova
Scotia, very modest background,
took the one-year course
to become a school teacher,
then journalist, then
member of parliament,
and then became
governor general.
And he thought one of the
most priceless features
of Canadian society
was volunteers,
people who just let their
time and their talent
to help others.
You can't put a price on it.
You just look at the
volunteers you know
and what a difference they make.
So he said, you know, we
recognize our great Order
of Canada people and people
of bravery and military merit
and so on.
But we should recognize
those unsung heroes.
So he started a
Caring Canadian Award.
And we went to
different towns, they
would confer this
Caring Canadian Award.
Then it got caught in budget
cuts about 15 years ago,
and it disappeared.
So when we came, talking about
the smart and caring nation,
we said, we should be putting
a focus on these volunteers,
not because they're
looking for attention,
but to encourage others to see
how important volunteerism is.
So we revived it.
And then, in discussions
with Her Majesty,
we asked if it could be
a queen-sanctioned honor.
So it's now called
the Sovereign's Medal
in Volunteerism.
And through the
Foundation, we've
developed an endowment so it can
never be hurt by budget cuts.
So we gave 1,000 out in
the last year I was there.
And our plan was
to go to 10,000.
And you say 10,000 is
a lot of certificates.
Well, there are 40,000
communities in this country.
Every one of those
have volunteers
that should be recognized.
And why do you do that?
You do that to encourage
that volunteer spirit
in the community,
and to cherish it,
and to promote it
as much as you can.
SPEAKER: Well, we could go on.
And I have many more questions.
But perhaps we should open
it up to any questions
that people might want to bring.
There's a microphone
up here, please.
DAVID JOHNSTON: Yeah, well I
was never asked, of course.
I was not asked to
prorogue Parliament.
But in fact, the
powers of proroguing,
which is postponing Parliament
for a bit, or dissolving,
which is to stop Parliament
and have a new election,
those are powers within the
office of the governor general.
But you take advice from the
elected form of government.
And the elected
form of government
is the prime minister and
the cabinet, et cetera.
So it would be--
only in the most
exceptional cases
would you exercise
that theoretical power
of refusing a request
to prorogue or dissolve.
And I could go into a bit
of length of what was truly,
truly exceptional
cases would be,
but even if it were
an exceptional case,
you'd look for something
other than an outright refusal
of the advice you were given.
You'd look for a delay.
You'd look for a
public explanation.
statement of reasons why.
And if it was something that you
thought was unconstitutional,
you probably would
consider a court reference.
And why do I say that?
It's because is the
governor general
is the representative
of the queen.
And that's an unelected
institution of government.
We believe in democracy
where you elect your rulers.
And therefore, one must
be careful, I think--
even where a power
exists in theory
in the unelected
form of government--
to exercise that power.
Because to do so means that
you are setting yourself
up as equally powerful
and more powerful
than the elected government.
And that goes back
to Lord Elgin in 1837
where he signed into law the
Lower Canada Rebellion Losses
Bill, which was passed
by a popular majority.
But the Family Compact,
the Senate of the day,
said don't sign that.
Exercise your powers.
There you are.
AUDIENCE: The electoral reform.
So the last two
federal governments
were majority
governments of 39%.
DAVID JOHNSTON: There's a
referendum actually going
on in British Columbia right
now at the provincial level.
It'll be the third one, I think.
I'm not sure.
This was a part of the platform
of the current government,
and it appears that the
reform they were looking for
isn't going to happen.
What I would say is that
the interesting thing
about our form of
government is that was not
born out of revolution.
It was born out of
evolution, point one.
Two, it's not perfect, but
it's pretty satisfactory.
And there's been
a genius, I think,
of Canadians who are people of
compromise to avoid extremes
and to find forms of
government that work.
And as we look at
this question, be it
forms of proportional
representation or something
else, my guess is
we'll approach it
in the same way of looking
at the alternatives
and evolving step by step.
Now, some may say
that's too slow.
Get some wise folks
together in a room
and draw something up
and get on with it.
But people often ask
me, you have in Canada
a constitutional monarchy with
a hereditary Monarch over there
in the United Kingdom.
Haven't you outgrown that?
Aren't you Canadians?
My answer is it works well.
And I happen to think it's
a good system of government.
Others could have their views,
and that's all being Canadian.
But I say that if you
look around the world
and you said, identify
eight or 10 countries who
have pretty satisfactory
governments that
by and large satisfy the
desires of their people,
you would find on that list
probably Sweden, Norway,
Denmark, United
Kingdom, Netherlands,
New Zealand, Australia, Canada.
What's common to those
eight or nine countries?
They're all constitutional
monarchies with pretty thriving
democracies.
And in our case, it's
evolved over 1,000 years
and it's served us
reasonably well.
So I guess that would be
my answer to any change
in our government.
Do it carefully
and thoughtfully,
and do it with broad
consensus, and avoid
instant and very
polarized things
like the Brexit referendum
in the United Kingdom.
I guess my view is that
that is an unfortunate
path for our friends in the UK.
Others will have
different views.
And by and large, I'm
not a great believer
in referenda for
fundamental change,
because referenda are
single-issue matters.
They are often very emotional.
They divide families.
They have not gone through
the digestion process
that we have with
political parties,
with platforms, with
second views of things,
including a Senate, et cetera.
And if you're going to make
pretty fundamental changes,
you want to proceed with
some degree of care.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVID JOHNSTON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question
about volunteerism.
DAVID JOHNSTON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So we basically have
two models in this country--
most countries--
for serving the public good.
And one of them is
volunteers, and another is
the professional civil service.
And they both have their
strong points and weak points.
With civil service, every
citizen has a right to things.
You don't have to ask someone.
You don't have to have
somebody take pity on you
or decide that you are worthy.
You just get it.
And for volunteerism,
of course, you
can draw from a much
broader range of people.
I'm just wondering how you feel
the balance between those two--
DAVID JOHNSTON: Yes.
I would not see
them as either/or.
I'd see them both ands for
a very practical reason.
The needs are so
great that I think
you need to get at them
from different ways.
And some people would say if
you're pushing volunteerism
all the time, it's because you
believe in small government,
and you don't want public
services, et cetera.
I think the world is
more complex than that.
And we should be
constantly redefining
what it is we expect
of governments
and what amount of taxes
we're prepared to pay to have
those services provided.
And in the Canadian
case, contrasting
with some other societies,
we have a pretty good faith
in government in
public services.
And we tend to be
more collective people
than an individualistic people.
And I think that's colored
how we've made these choices.
But at the same time, by
and large, volunteerism
thrives in this country.
And I think it thrives
because we're essentially--
apart from our First
Nations people,
who have pretty good volunteer
arrangements themselves--
we're a nation of immigrants.
And each wave of immigrants
that has come to this country
usually has come from a
very difficult background.
They've come from despair, from
war, from poverty, from hunger.
My case, my Scottish ancestors
were kicked off the land
because sheep were more
important than people.
And they settled in
Northern Ireland,
displacing poor
Catholic farmers.
So Protestants were there
and then ran out of potatoes
and came to Canada always
with the determination
that life shall be
better for our children.
And that has not just
been for our children.
It's been for our community
and a sense of barn raising
that is part of the
Canadian spirit.
And that's where the
volunteer is in common,
and so I think you want
both of those engines
functioning really
well, with any luck,
interacting with one another,
not duplicating one another.
But I wouldn't be
suppressing one or the other
because you think, innately,
that one shouldn't happen.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I Was wondering what you thought
about transparency and trust.
If there's distrust
of institutions,
if you're transparent,
that gives them evidence
to further their distrust.
DAVID JOHNSTON: Well,
in the initial instance,
that's correct.
You know, get out all
the secrets, et cetera.
But at some point, those secrets
are either going to get out,
or the thing is
going to make some
so distrustful it doesn't work.
So to me, the only
answer is transparency.
And the beauty of
transparency is once you've
laid the problem out--
and the errors-- then you get
on the more difficult task
of rebuilding the trust.
I began thinking
about this, actually,
when I was a young
law professor and I
was research counsel to the
Ontario Securities Commission.
We were rewriting the economic
regulation for the markets.
And transparency,
openness, full disclosure
were the kind of watchwords
to build trust in the markets
so you could trust the markets
to make your investments,
et cetera, that we could see the
markets as reasonable measures
of value, et cetera.
And by and large, that system
works pretty well in Canada.
But it's based on the notion
of trust and transparency.
The other thing I would say
is where something wrong
has gone on, then I
think you should be fully
transparent in dealing with it.
So we have a chapter in
the book about apology,
the importance of apology.
And we begin by saying,
no book on trust in Canada
could be written without
speaking of the First Nations
situation in the
residential schools.
And so that chapter is
almost entirely devoted
to the apology for the
residential schools.
One of the few places in the
book where we quote at length,
one Prime Minister's Harper's
apology in the House of Commons
in 2011, and Prime
Minister Trudeau's
further reconciliation
statement in 2016, I think.
And you have to make the apology
full, complete, transparent,
not carving it up,
and then you get
on with the steps of rebuilding
trust, the reconciliation.
So transparency
is the first step,
but there are others after it.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
AUDIENCE: So almost everyone
of us here in this room
are probably
post-secondary educated
on one of the core skills
we learned at university
and that was critical thinking.
And part of trust,
at least for me,
is about being one's challenge.
Challenge the people.
DAVID JOHNSTON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Like you
think critically
about what they're saying.
DAVID JOHNSTON: It's
not blind trust.
AUDIENCE: Right.
DAVID JOHNSTON:
It's informed trust.
AUDIENCE: And so
it seems that there
is a fundamental degradation
in critical thinking
in our society today.
What's your opinion of how
critical thinking and trust
fit together and whether--
DAVID JOHNSTON: Well, I
think it's always been
the most important ingredient.
And the question why has
been the most important.
And it goes back to
Plato and Socrates.
And it's especially
important now--
critical thinking-- in
asking the right questions,
because we have
an ocean of data.
And for the first
time, teachers are not
the fountain of knowledge.
And we have to learn how to
go from data to information
to knowledge to wisdom.
And we do that through
informed questions, eh?
Especially when all
the data's there,
you just have to know the
search paths and the questions
to bring it together.
I'm a teacher.
And Tom Friedman's
book, "Thanks for Being
Late" talks about
this age of disruption
and the very phenomenon
you've spoken about that trust
can be eroded and we get
information in different ways.
So he says, what's the answer?
The answer is the three Rs.
Go back to teach reading, and
writing, and arithmetic well.
But then he said, we must
also teach the four Cs.
And they are Creativity,
Communication, Collaboration,
and Coding.
We talk about this in
the book on innovation
that Tom and I wrote.
And I believe in
the first three.
I didn't believe in
the fourth, coding.
But Thomas swung me
along, not because I
want every kid to be a coder.
But I think it's
instructive to learn
enough about how you
code to see that that's
a new way of thinking.
It's a new curiosity path.
And as you understand
that system,
it helps you to see
the benefits that
come from using code but
thinking in different ways.
And the final thing I would say
is that for me, those four Cs
are helpful.
But there's a C that's
even more important.
And that's curiosity.
What you want to do is
enhance the curiosity.
And so our five daughters
began international exchanges
at age 12.
And it was the best
thing that could
have happened to
their formation,
or their development,
as we say in French.
Through international exposure,
exposure to different cultures,
and exposure to poverty,
four things happen to them.
One, their curiosity
became enhanced.
They had always been
kids that asked why.
But the whys were
more penetrating whys.
Secondly, they
became more tolerant.
Not tolerant just sense of,
you're different from me.
That's OK.
Nobody gets hurt, but,
why are you different,
and, what is your
background, and so
on, a true interest in it.
Thirdly, their
judgment became better.
They were quick to spot bigotry.
They wanted to hear
another side of the story.
They wanted to
triangulate to get
the proper measure of things.
But fourthly, they became
more empathetic, not just
sympathetic, but empathetic.
They could walk in the
other person's shoes.
And so I guess that's
the kind of formation
that I would be seeing in how
we function in a resilient
way to this new age, that
we don't have blind trust,
we have informed trust, and that
we work constantly to enhancing
our informed nature.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So first off, as
a Waterloo alumni,
we first talked, probably, about
several decades ago while I
was an undergrad at Waterloo.
So first of all, I actually
wanted to thank you.
Yes, I was that tall.
[LAUGHTER]
I wanted to thank you
for all the service
that you've provided
to the university,
and to the region of Waterloo,
and to the country now,
on behalf of the country
itself was my first thought.
I actually had a question.
But it's a little tradition
to start with a saying.
[LAUGHTER]
So my question is
about digital trust.
So we have created this
world, this environment,
where we have
digitized and scaled up
social interaction in
the form of social media,
that every interaction you can
create in a social setting you
can now make in a
digital, social setting.
But one thing that we haven't
been able to digitize,
and you can see
that this has been
abused by state
actors and [INAUDIBLE]
is the idea of digital trust.
How do we create--
how do I know that when
I engage on social media
that the information
that's being given to me
is trustworthy?
How do I know who is at the
other end of the computer?
And as a company,
I think, we have
an interest in thinking
about how do we
solve this general problem
of trust in the digital age?
We have communities
that are small,
but we are trying
to build platforms
that can connect us globally.
In order to do that, we need
some sort of digital platform.
So my question to you
is how do we build trust
in a digital realm, and how do
we establish as an organization
that remote digital
form of trust?
DAVID JOHNSTON: Well, I think
you begin with just what you've
done today.
Get up and say, we
think we have an issue.
And who better to
get at that issue
than people that
think about it a lot
and have the tools
to develop the rules
of the road, the service.
That'd be point one.
Point two is, again,
in Tom Friedman's book,
"Thanks for Being Late."
He deals with this issue.
And he refers to one of
the two or three people
that have been great
mentors with him.
And this individual says we're
in a kind of the second round,
I guess, of a 15-round boxing
match or the second inning
of a ninth-inning ballgame.
The first inning was the
wonderful, remarkable,
technological development.
It took three centuries
for the printing press
to reach a majority of the
population of Western Europe.
It took the internet
between 1995 and 2005--
less than a decade--
to reach a majority
of the world's population.
That, in itself, is a remarkable
technological accomplishment.
But he said inning
two, or round two,
is developing the
rules of the road
with these dramatically new
and different tools that
have great potential for
good, but also have potential
for harm.
And I guess as the internet
came along, some of us
were of the view,
let this market be
as free as it possibly
can be so that you
don't stifle innovation.
And then you say, mmm,
maybe there are some rules.
But the rules, I think,
would be best developed
from within these
industries, from people
like yourselves who understand
not only current practices,
but the practices to come,
rather than governments
doing the whole job.
And of course,
ideally, what you will
have is the thoughtful people
in the industry identifying
the problems now, and the
problems that will come,
and solutions, and
where government
is necessary to
have government act.
But it's not it's the
government with the big stick,
and they'll come along
and do the hitting,
and meanwhile, the wrongs,
or the unfortunate practices,
continue to grow
and grow and people
develop a distrust of the
ability of the people managing
those enterprises to come up
with the rules of the road.
You know, every
period in history
has these big disruptions.
And it takes thoughtfulness
to learn how to rejig.
And the changes are enormous.
But you think of the printing
press in Western Europe.
That was resisted
for the longest time,
because the Catholic
Church controlled religion.
And the most important
thing in the Middle Ages
to anyone in Western Europe
was your relationship with God.
But that was managed
by a bureaucracy
with a priest, bishop, cardinal,
and pope, and in a language
that people didn't understand.
And you certainly wouldn't
want to have them understand
what the Bible said or
why you have the sacrament
of holy communion.
You do it in Latin.
It's awe and mystery.
And what happened with the
invention of the printing
press-- it wasn't invented
in Western Europe.
It was actually
invented in South Korea
about 1,000 years before.
But it didn't develop there--
was people began to read
that truth for themselves.
And they disintermediated.
So they didn't need a
priest, and a bishop,
and a cardinal, and
magnificent cathedrals.
And what happened
from that, of course,
was not only did people
learn about the religion they
felt important, but
they then realized
how important education was.
And that was the
breakdown of serfdom,
the rise of the
cities in Europe,
the Industrial Revolution,
the democratic institutions
of parliament and so on,
and Europe leapt ahead
of Islam, India,
and China, which
were much more advanced
civilizations until about 1600,
1700.
So long story short
to say, yeah, I
think we will need
some rules of the road,
and you are the people who
are best designed to do them.
Just a few months ago, I was
speaking here on tech for Good
at the tech conference.
And we'll have a repeat
of that in a year.
When is the next
conference, Amy?
AMY: June.
DAVID JOHNSTON: In June?
AMY: Yes.
DAVID JOHNSTON: Good.
So that Tech for
Good speech was just
about what we're
talking about now.
SPEAKER: Thank you [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID JOHNSTON: Time's up.
SPEAKER: Thank you for the time.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]